ce coup d'accélérateur dans le projet de
la seconde ligne de tramway elle doit
relier la riche à chambray à partir de
2025 et bien son tracé considérés comme
définitifs vient d'être dévoilée par la
métropole ce qui retient l'attention
c'est son passage par bérenger il
devrait entraîner un réaménagement
complet de la place jean jaurès ce n'est
qu'une petite partie du tracé mais ô
combien symbolique celui de la place
jean jaurès deux options se disputaient
jusqu'à présent la première un passage
par le boulevard heurteloup la seconde
par la rue charlot gilles puis l'avenue
de grammont en utilisant les rails de la
ligne une
c'est donc cette dernière que les élus
ont choisi on a trouvé un autre tracé
qui permet de préserver le patrimoine
arboré sur le boulevard heurteloup ce
qui est une bonne chose
il permet de résoudre si d'autres
contraintes techniques
un tracé qui va néanmoins entraîner un
bouleversement urbain et historique une
restructuration complète de
l'emblématique place jean jaurès en
effet pour tourner boulevard béranger le
tram va devoir passer par l'actuel
emplacement des fontaines elles
pourraient disparaître au profit d'un
nouveau visage
c'est une opportunité pour les un réseau
de s'emparer des sept possibilités de
reconfigurer notre place centrale une
reconfiguration totale permettrait de
conserver des points d'eau avoir une
végétalisation 6 plus forte
et puis libéré de l'espace public pour
la population dernier changement majeur
sur ce secteur un passage du tramway au
nord du boulevard béranger
pour le reste ce tracé reste fidèle dans
les grandes lignes à celui d'origine
départ du prieuré saint côme al-arich
passage par les hôpitaux la gare de
tours le quartier du sanitas et des
fontaines trousseau et enfin chambray au
terminus et des parkings relais
quatre ans après les premières études ce
tracé est présenté comme définitif
évidemment beaucoup de débats beaucoup
des changes en cours avec les habitants
mais ce tracé voilà il est là il est
prêt si on doit choisir notre maître
d'oeuvre dans quelques semaines et donc
il était absolument nécessaire de faire
un choix et de l'affirmer ce tracé sera
soumis au vote du conseil municipal de
tours le 9 novembre avant l' enquête
publique
l'an prochain la mise en service du
tramway est annoncée pour fin 2011 25